a query that processes a trillion rows
per second on the current version of M
sequel so being able to process data
this fast really can kind of change the
kind of things you might consider as an
application architect or a data
warehouse architect a bi architect
someone who's architecting an
operational data store for analytics you
know it really can open up some new
vistas for you so we'll talk about that
and we'll talk about you know the impact
of being able to the process data this
fast so just to get started I just
wanted to see how many people have heard
of mem sequel before ok great
so a little more than half so mem sequel
is a is a relational database system
it's really a general-purpose relational
database system so I'll talk in detail
about the capabilities of mem sequel and
you know what it can do a little bit
later in this talk I'm gonna go over mem
sequel I'm gonna also talk about
interactive response time and how that's
relates to user satisfaction and some
kind of intuitive things that you know
people have observed with really fast
response time I'm also going to talk
about state-of-the-art query execution
technology as it's used in MEMS sequel
and what it can provide how it a little
bit about how it works and then I'll
demonstrate for you doing a trillion
rows per second scan and talk a little
bit about where we can go with this
technology in terms of application
architecture and application development
for for analytics so first of all MEMC
quasi said is an SQL database so it
supports standard ansi sequel and it's
really really fast so it supports scale
out compiled queries so compile queries
to machine code
rather than interpreting queries which
is what most other systems do its uses
in memory roasts or data structures for
transaction management and a disk based
column store structure for analytics but
actually the even the roast or structure
is so fast you can do some amazing
analytical workloads on it we and we
support vectorized query execution
including sort of conventional
vectorized career execution which I'll
describe more later as well as using sim
D or single instruction multiple data to
operate really fast on data even before
it gets into the regular Korea execution
pipeline so mem sequel as I said is a
general-purpose system that can support
both transactions and analytics it's
really fantastic as an operational data
store so an operational data store is
you know that term is used in a number
of different ways different ways but the
most common way to use it is it's a
system that sits right next to your
operational transaction processing
system or systems and you can ingest
data from those transaction processing
systems in real time very quickly so the
data in your operational data store is a
copy of what's in your transaction
system but it's then you can perform
analytics on it without impacting the
the transactional store so mem sequel is
is good for transactions it's good for
data warehousing and analytics but it
really shines as an operational data
store where it enables analytics on very
large operational data sets without
impacting the transaction system so why
do you why would one consider using them
sequel first it can ingest data really
fast has very low latency query and
supports very high concurrency so
hundreds of concurrent users can be
running some substantial queries at the
same time and getting interactive
response time so memfs equals
architecture is a scale out architecture
similar what you've seen with Hadoop or
Tara data at
but the a client application connects to
a front-end node which we call an
aggregator and then the aggregator farms
out pieces of a query across multiple
back-end nodes which we call leaf nodes
so challenges to getting really fast or
lightning-fast response time are large
data volumes of course lots of
concurrency many concurrent users query
complexity and rapidly changing data so
if if you've got all of these things
working against you you need you know
that you've got some challenges to get
interactive response time and when I say
interactive I'm talking about sub-second
response time for substantial analytical
queries so there's a some interesting
observations and you can make about
response time user productivity and user
satisfaction so now I'll say a few words
about about those things but before I
get into that I just want to tell you a
personal story about my personal
experience with response time for
analytical query processing and this is
not meant to be representative this is
just my personal story some milestones
and my memory related to query
processing and career response time so
sort of in around 2006 I was a program
manager at Microsoft and the SQL Server
team responsible for data warehousing
enhancements and you know sequel server
at that time really wasn't anywhere and
that you know with you know it wasn't
really a player in the data warehousing
market and so the team wanted to invest
in that area so did some experiments I
loaded up a hundred million rows on a
small server like a four core server
this is back in 2006 when they're you
know chips I'd like one core so it took
three minutes to run a query to scan one
million rows on a small server so you
know the CPU could process like a
hundred million rows per second excuse
me about one to two million rows per
second per quart
but the system was i/o bound you know
the disks were the limiting factor so it
took a really long time so a hundred
million rows of data said to me at the
time it sounded like a lot of data but
it was you know it took three minutes to
run a query against it when you had the
machine dedicated to you know
concurrency at all so that was kind of
disappointing but learned about column
stores we introduced a column store in a
sequel server and it could do a hundred
million rows per second per core so a
next kind of memorable milestone in my
experience of interactive response time
was 2012 six years later I loaded up 100
million rows and I was able to process
it on a small server in about a third of
a second end to end so that was a pretty
amazing increase but a hundred million
rows is you know it's it's a substantial
data set but it's not like an enterprise
data set for a fortune 100 company it's
just not that big so for larger data
sets you were still not going to get
interactive response time but you know
that's a dramatic I mean that's like
three orders of magnitude improvement in
six years okay fast forward six more
years to 2018
so with mem sequel I'm going to
demonstrate for you today running a
query on 448 cores on a cluster a small
cluster small in terms of number of
nodes but actually quite a lot of course
being able to process 57.8 billion rows
in one twentieth of a second so again I
don't do the exact math but it's around
another three orders of magnitude
improvement so we're it's like a million
times improvement from 2000 from 12
years ago so just you know technology
has advanced so much in the last
you know 10 to 15 years with respect to
analytical query processing we can
really start to expect interactive
response time for very large queries in
a concurrent environment all right so I
was I'm gonna talk a little bit now
about you know response time and
productivity and user satisfaction so
here's an interesting quote which I
enjoy about sort of what it feels like
to interact with a system what response
you know how response time can impact
people it's related to that stimulation
is the indispensable requisite for
pleasure in an experience and the
feeling of bare time is the least
stimulating experience we can have bare
time means waiting around for something
to happen
just waiting with nothing to stimulate
you so when users run a report or are
trying to perform some analytics on a
computer system if they have to wait
around for more than a few seconds it
starts to get tedious so this isn't
something that people just recognize
this is from a psychology textbook from
1890 so psychologists understood you
know people like they like stimulation
they don't want to wait for things so
users can become used to speed you know
once they interact with a computing
system that's really fast they get used
to it they expect that kind of response
so our end users today are used to you
know running a Google query on any you
know any phone or laptop and getting an
answer back and frack a fraction of a
second or probably under a second almost
all the time and so they're kind of
spoiled they're you they're used to
doing things which seem to be
challenging and potentially you know big
tasks but having it be interactive so
and of course as you would expect you
know psychological research on
human-computer interaction shows that
satisfaction increases as a response
time did decrease decreases surprise
surprise
so other interesting things that people
have learned studying human-computer
interaction with respect to response
time or that delays of even 50 to 150
milliseconds are perceptible in
real-time applications
so most reporting applications are not
really real-time applications real-time
applications are things like virtual
reality gaming and you know pressing a
key on the keyboard and seeing the
letter show up in your text editor stuff
like that so if the delays are more than
even 50 milliseconds people can perceive
it in those kind of applications but
that shows kind of the limit of human
perception of response time and
application though people can feel it if
if your app is even 50 milliseconds
faster 10 responding and 250
milliseconds is about the median human
reaction time so like if someone like
takes a swipe at your face or something
it's going to take you like a quarter of
a second to raise your arm and protect
yourself unless you're like a fighter
pilot or something like that in which
case maybe you won the genetic lottery
and you've got a lot of practice and
you're like 120 milliseconds that's kind
of the peak human response time you know
you know all-star computer gaming
wizards and fighter jocks can have like
100 20 millisecond response time so you
know if response time you see that
response time graph you know so response
time takes a minute people are extremely
bored they will not sit still for a
minute they'll get up and leave they'll
go do something else
if response time takes 10 seconds there
it's fat it feels tedious people will
sit still but they don't feel real happy
they don't feel real good about their
experience of the app the analytical
application response time down to about
a second that's really quite good and
response time of around a quarter of a
second is phenomenal meaning that the
Pieta feels almost instantaneous so
anything less than like a quarter of a
second you know because that's human
reaction time
or it feels nearly instantaneous in it
you know when you get down below 150 to
even 50 milliseconds if it's faster than
that it is instantaneous you can't
perceive any delay so why am I talking
about this well it just so it turns out
I already gave a spoiler which is I'm
going to show you running a trillion
rows per second query on mem sequel
which has incredible interactive
response time but you know so assuming
that we can get super interactive
response time for analytical query
environments what should we know about
that what are some subtleties that might
occur well it turns out that users high
variance in response time bothers users
it can make them uncomfortable and make
them really not you know not feel good
about their interaction with the
computing system they're using
unfortunately this means either away so
if the variance if it's less than what
the response time is less than 1/4 of
the mean response time that they've
become accustomed to or more than twice
the mean response time that they've
become accustomed to they they can feel
displeasure with the using the the
computing system and so it can help if
you can't if you can detect this and
give a message that are warning to the
user that they're experiencing a delay
or if you even if they get an incredibly
fast response you might want to even
give a reassuring message hey don't
worry this is the you know we're able to
produce the answer and it's the correct
answer it's a little quicker than usual
why is that well unexpectedly fast
results can make users apprehensive so
what does that mean so I saw I've seen
this where some some users of mem sequel
may you know they may have upgraded to a
newer release and now a query that used
to take 10 seconds takes like a tenth of
a second and they press ENTER and it
goes boom and it comes back and they're
like whoa
something is wrong here I don't think
that I think the system might have not
be maybe it was giving me a cached
result or something I don't know if I
trust this so yeah
fortunately users get used to with
things really quickly so that feeling of
uneasiness will pass quickly once they
get used to using the system but
interestingly people can become
apprehensive just do a really fast
results if they're not used to the idea
so some other important things to know
about fast response are that very fast
response times can lead to more what are
so-called input errors by the user now
why is that is because it's so easy to
run to use the system again to make
another input that you know they don't
think as hard as they should before they
enter their query or their command to
the system so you know if inputs take
like 10 seconds to give you a response
you're gonna think pretty hard or before
you press the Enter key
you're gonna look at the form that you
filled out and you're gonna make sure
that everything's good so
now really fast interactive response
time however does have some you know
much more benefits than drawbacks and
that it can make users interact with the
system and explore much more readily so
if a system doesn't give like
interactive response time they might run
a few queries and stop or give up if it
provides interactive response time they
might make dozens of changes to their
their search requests or their report
design or whatever run it again and
again to explore it so this is really
great because it creates more business
value you know the users use the system
more they're going to learn more about
the data you're where we as data
architects you're trying to build
systems that allow them to explore data
and learn some something from it and
take action to improve business somehow
so interactive response time is just is
just a big win in that respect so I want
to say a few more words about mmm sequel
query execution technology and how we
get really fast interactive response
time in memfs equal so we we use
scale-out as i mentioned before we
compile queries to machine code we don't
you know compared to interpreting them
which is done in other systems we have
an in-memory row store and a disk based
column store column store is the where
we have the fastest query execution
technology but the roast or query
execution capability is very good also
I'll say give you some numbers and we
also have vectorized query execution
which I'll describe a little bit and we
use single instruction multiple data how
many of people have heard of sim D or a
single instruction multiple data okay so
I'll get into that and I'll give you an
explanation of how that works so as I
alluded to before mem sequel uses scale
out we have true horizontal scaling you
know we we shard data across multiple
back-end nodes called leaf nodes and
it's not shared disk or shared shared
storage we actually partition the data
across multiple nodes so that when you
run of queries scan in parallel all the
Leafs can work independently with no
interference with each other you can
resize the cluster you can make it
bigger or smaller and redistribute data
you also can add you can add aggregators
or leaves to expand the cluster if you
want and this can scale both
transactions and analytics so as I said
mem sequel compiles queries to machine
code and so this is an example based on
our roast or technology so you can see
here that I've got let's see how many
rows about 8 million rows in a table tea
and I just ran this on on my macbook it
only has two cores so this is using the
row store technology that I described
and the so the first query is just count
select count star from T where color
equals red so it's gonna scan T and it's
gonna have to evaluate a predicate on
one column so it's a pretty simple query
it's you know it's one of this more
simple queries you can do on mem sequel
but it is scanning and looking at every
single row it's not using an index and
so it ran that query the first time in
forty two hundredths of a second and
then I ran it again and I ran it in
seventeen hundreds of a second so the
first time included compile time art was
generating machine code to run that
query and then the last time it's
actually already compiled that query so
it's running it from cache and so it's
actually running that query at 49
million rows per second on two cores so
that's almost 25 million rows per second
per core so compare that to one to two
million rows per second per core and a
typical interpreted database system
that's using a row store like like an
Oracle or a my sequel or a postcard
or whatever so this is darn good you
know this is what you know an order of
magnitude or more faster than something
that the the the kind of roast or
database that most people are using
today and mem sequel also has a column
store which is going to be the basis of
the demonstration I'm going to do for
you so this is on disk the the row store
from M sink sequel is an in-memory data
structure called the Skip list it uses
lock-free algorithms so we have very
high concurrency control when accessing
information in memfs equal our column
store it's on disk and it breaks the
data into 1 million row chunks called
segments and each column is stored in a
separate file within a segment so we
when you're running a query most queries
touch a lot fewer columns than there are
total columns in the table so a typical
table might have 40 columns but your
query might only touch like 6 columns so
you don't have to read every column and
that is one of the benefits of column
store so column store data and mem
sequel is highly compressed we use a
number of different compression
techniques including dictionary encoding
run length encoding Lempel Ziv encoding
and integer value encoding and we store
a minimum and maximum value for each
column for each segment so we can do
what's called segment elimination when
you're scanning the data if there's a
range filter you don't have to read a
segment if you can rule out the entire
segment by looking at the min max values
per column some more information out the
column store we sort the column stores
by key there's a key for every column
store and the data is sorted by that key
I mentioned segment elimination so
compiled code is built into the system
for handling column store queries the
Linux file buffer cache is used to keep
data in RAM so we don't actually have a
buffer pool in memory for our disk based
column store but the data is in memory
if you've accessed it recently because
it's in the Linux file system buffer
pool
so we do have to copy data from the
Linux file buffer pool into mem sequel
but because it's so highly compressed
that tends not to be the bottleneck and
newly you can insert update and delete
data in a column store transactionally
in real time in memfs equals so we use
an in-memory roast or segment to hold
the new inserted data so if you insert a
row and a column store it takes it takes
like whoops excuse me
it takes fraction of a millisecond it
just goes straight into the in-memory
row store and and there's a background
merger that when the roast store gets
full the row of stores segment gets full
it'll compress it and write it off into
a column store format segment and that
all happens in the background without
any user intervention so now we're
getting to the the meat of the matter
about how the inner loop of query
execution and mem sequel is so fast so
we used vectorized query execution and
sim D and I'll talk about both of those
so with vectorization we process data
you know in instead of one row at a time
we process data and 4,000 row chunks
called we call it a vector projection so
this this technology this kind of
technology was actually introduced in
mode a dbx 100 and there was a lot of
research on it about you know over the
last 15 years but it's it's known to
really speed up query execution by like
two orders of magnitude because you
amortize the cost of interpreting each
row you just interpret one 4,000 row
block at a time and then if you need to
do something like filter 4,000 row block
by applying a filter to one column you
can grab this that column which is kept
in an array of a primitive data type
like 64-bit words and just scan that
that array really fast in a really tight
loop of C code you can say filter the
entire 4,000 row block and if you know
in very little time
so this kind of vectorization can lead
to being able to process like one or two
or even three hundred million rows per
second per core for those kind of
operations but you can do even better so
you can push you can push filter and
group by aggregate type operations down
to the scan layer to the storage layer
before it even reaches the curry
execution layer and so we that's what we
do in in memfs equal four group by
aggregates and filters on our column
store and we use SIMD or sim D to even
accelerate that process further so a few
words about sim D so mem sequel uses the
Intel avx2
instruction set which is for single
instruction multiple data to accelerate
certain operations and this instruction
set allows you to operate on 256 bit
registers so all the Intel chips or the
last four years or so have a V X to
support it's all in your favorite cloud
or in your data center and you can do
things like you can pack say for 64-bit
integers into a single 256 bit register
you have to such registers and you can
add them and add the words pairwise so
you can do one add you can do an ADD of
four pairs of numbers in the time it
would take you to do an ADD of one pair
of numbers with this regular 64-bit
register so sim D is a low level
parallelism mechanism that allows you to
do arithmetic and logic operations on on
multiple sub words within a larger 56
bit register you know in a single
instruction do it really fast so we use
operation we use sim D to do what we
call operations on encoded data in memfs
equal and also I'll give you an example
of that a little bit later we can do
both filters and group by aggregates
push down to the storage level on these
thousands on these million Road segments
that I mentioned earlier
so you can process a 256-bit chunk of
encoded or compressed data at once so
that can actually be multiple rows worth
of data can be packed into a single 256
bit register from a single column and so
you can do like you can operate on like
dozens of rows of data in a single
instruction by using sim d-- and that's
one way we're getting able to get this
really fast sort of scan rate that I
talked about so this is again applied
before the vectorization stuff that I
described already we do it as we're
scanning the data down at the storage
layer before we copy it out into those
4,000 roadblocks that I mentioned that
are called vector projections so again I
mentioned encoded data but what is
encoded data so if you look at the the
diagram here suppose I have a table
called T in its column store and it's
got a color column and there's three
values of color green red and blue so
you can represent each of those with
exactly two bits so we can keep a
dictionary and use dictionary encoding
and then it only takes two bits to
represent a color and so we can pack
that very tightly into a file that
represents the data for that column and
that's one way we're able to get such a
good compression with columnstore but we
can take advantage of that during curry
execution and we can pack a bunch of
two-bit values together and store them
in a single SIMD or sim d register and
operate them on them at once while we're
doing a query like that which is a group
by aggregate query and so we can do
local aggregation at the storage layer
level before forwarding up to the rest
of query execution and by operating on
those two-bit values you know very
regularly formatted integers rather than
hashing and comparing character strings
you can save a huge amount of time as
you can imagine
so now I'd like to demonstrate to you a
query running at a trillion rows per
second and I want to thank our partners
Intel for helping us achieve this result
and Intel graciously loaned us access to
some skylake servers running in their
lab in Phoenix Arizona and these so I'm
I'm going to use a cluster which has
this layout there's not a teef nodes and
one aggregator and I'm going to connect
to the aggregator and run a query those
leaf nodes have two Intel Xeon Platinum
81 ATS they're called skylake chips with
that clock rate they have 28 cores each
chip so each leaf actually has you know
each leaf node actually has two chips
two processors so the total number of
cores is 2 is 8 times 2 times 28 which
is 448 cores at the leaf level and then
there's some 56 chords on the aggregator
also the aggregator is the same that
I've got storing data on the aggregator
so the data for this demonstration is
synthetically generated data about stock
trades so I simulated trades on the
Nasdaq Stock Exchange which is the stock
exchange for a lot of tech stocks and
other stocks in this country it's got a
little bit more than 3,000 total
companies listed on the exchange
so I generated 57.8 billion rows of
randomly generated trade data and so I
want to demonstrate for you a trillion
row per second it's really in row per
second scan so how big is a trillion you
can put things in perspective it's the
amount of money on a football field
covered with hunt stacks of $100 bills
six feet high it's the number of tweets
and five years it's a number of text
messages in
world in the entire world in about 45
days and it's more than the number of
checkout transactions at Walmart since
it was founded not line items but actual
checkout transactions so all right well
let's I've said it enough time so let's
actually do it here okay so before I get
into this I just want to show you how
big the table is so that's a select
count star query that counts the number
of rows in this table trade which has
the stock trades
this is just like how the data looks
it's you know it just has stock symbol
share share price and time and so let's
go back and now I'm gonna run a query to
get the top 10 most traded stocks okay
you see that so yeah it's just it's a
query that does you know it's grouping
by stock symbol and counting the note
total number of rows with that symbol
and ordering ordering by the count in
descending order and then doing a limit
10 to give me the top 10 and so look at
that it came back in 5 one hundredths of
a second ok and you can see that I've
the way I generated the data it's skewed
towards the larger capitalization stocks
and so you see some big names there like
Cisco and Amazon they're on the top 10
which is what you would expect so now if
I want to know how many rows person per
second you know I'm processing you know
I had like a few more digits of
resolution than that this is only
accurate to one significant figure so
I'm gonna do another I wrote a stored
procedure here basically to run that
same query in a loop n times you can see
that stored procedure at the bottom of
the screen on the right I just want to
see how long that takes so that I can
like get more significant figures before
I calculate my rows per second rate so I
run that so this this is now running out
a hundred times in a loop and it took
five point four point three four seconds
so I can go over here and put in
five three four so this this will give
us our scan rate and see I'm even using
that format function because I the the
numbers have so many digits I need the
commas in order to read them so alright
so that's one point zero eight one
trillion rows per second how about that
trillion rows per second okay yeah so
that this is actually running live on
that 448 core cluster that intel
generously allowed us to use that's in
Phoenix with the latest skylake chips
and so let's talk a little bit about the
economics of this yeah those are state
of the art servers that's kind of
expensive but really not that expensive
in the grand scheme of things those
servers are probably and the and the
they're you know with all their memory
and storage and the chips they're
probably like thirty five thousand
dollars a piece but you know the amount
of money that you can make or save with
a really good analytical application for
a huge enterprise
you know is a lot bigger than the price
of that hardware and the mem sequel
software so let me wrap up
okay so I did it before and I got a
little bit better rate it depends on you
know what equipment you're using how the
network is feeling that day and stuff
but it's about the same
so just to recap you know what does this
mean to you as an as a data architect so
you can really you know the technology
exists today where you can really
encourage analytical exploration in your
user base now you can the technology
exists to meet all the challenges of the
expects potations of fast interactive
response time like fraction of a second
response time data explosion high
concurrency preference for SQL as the
data language because people know SQL
and that you know non-technical or only
semi technical users can learn how to
use it real time update not just static
data warehouse or big data kind of
environments and the need to run on
economical hardware you know industry
standard hardware and the need to run
anywhere including either your data
center or your favorite cloud platform
so that kind of technology exists mem
sequel can handle that and so ask
yourself you know what kind of response
time could you get with your data and
how might that impact the productivity
of your user base that's using your
analytical applications and so we we
have a developer edition that you can
download for free I please go out and
download it try it out and the you know
so for for development and testing you
know there's no scale limits you can you
know use it to your heart's content so
thank you very much you mentioned table
t as an example in most of the slide
right is it stored as row store and
column store both or when we create a
table we specify how it is stored when
you create the table you specify whether
it's a column store or a store a default
is row store or you can you can use in
your create table command you can
specify column store so the demo that
you showed is it on columns yeah that
demo is on column store yes
you